the new cabinet have you got a new job I
have no idea looks remarkably similar to
some old ones and maybe he's going for a
stroll down uh Whitehall
Dominic Robb back as Deputy Prime
Minister and Justice secretary I think
he gave a very powerful
humble
clear speech on the steps of number 10
down the street I think he's gonna be
the right guy to leave this country but
even he struggled to get in the building
Michael Gove returns as leveling up
secretary the job Boris Johnson sacked
him from in July what do you make of
Rishi sunak as a prime minister do we
need a change in this country
you seem he seems strangely silent Mr
Gove
I'll call you right thank you that the
most controversial Resurrection is that
of sowella Braverman oh I'm absolutely
delighted uh
farishi sunak for the conservative party
for the country six days after being
fired for a security breach she's
already back running the home office
Rishi sunax said at noon he wanted a
government of integrity and
professionalism and then five hours
later he reappointed the Home Secretary
who had to resign less than a week ago
for breaching the ministerial code for
security lapses and this just looks like
not taking seriously our national
security and our Public Safety this is
largely a continuity cabinet with few
fresh faces those running the treasury
foreign office and Ministry of Defense
all remain in post one surprise Rishi
sunak's leadership rival penny mordant
has not been promoted she's said to be
furious that she's staying as leader of
the house but elsewhere hints on policy
the new work and pension secretary Mel
stride backs up racing benefits in line
with inflation
seasoned white who watches seem
encouraged one of the things that really
hobbled both Boris Johnson's cabinet and
his trusses cabinet was that they really
had people who were chosen for loyalty
first and competence second it does help
to have dissenting voices because if you
like
you get early warning of the troubles
your policies might run into if you
don't just cram your cabinet full with
people who are absolutely of the same
mindset as the top team this morning Liz
truss and her cabinet posed for one
final photo following her out the door
11 of her top team sacked by Rishi sunak
with 10 keeping their jobs and others
moved to new roles for all those moving
to Whitehall others are heading in the
opposite direction give us a minute
please thank you thanks so much like
sacked foreign office Minister Vicki
Ford some of us need to move on in order
to make sure that he has got room to
bring in some really good talent from
all across the party clearing out her
desk before returning to the back
benches I now have the ability to speak
slightly more freely than I may have
done when I was sitting in a different
place within hours of his sacking sunac
critic Jacob Reese MOG already seemed to
have adapted to his new life
without their government cars
ex-ministers will be getting used to
public transport once again there is a
new regime in town well aware the clock
is ticking down to the next German
election
Joe Pike Sky News Westminster